avec nous nos mii banda président du
collectif inter urgence est infirmière
aux urgences d'oloron sainte marie
bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt finances alors que pensez vous de
l'appel du secrétaire général de la cfdt
laurent berger bonjour ce que j'en pense
décès comme pour nous dans le à
l'hôpital public
ils ont les mêmes difficultés que nous
les conditions de travail sont
déplorables les moyens sont sont
inexistantes
donc forcément pays méritent la même
hausse de salaire que que nous on a pu
avoir même si ce n'est pas suffisant et
ce n'est pas encore à la hauteur de ce
qu'on demande mais le soucis financiers
pour pour les salaires sont les mêmes
partout dans le médical dans le
médico-social peu importe il faut pas
faire de différence voilà ce que j'en
pense aujourd'hui est-ce que la crise
sanitaire a mis en lumière finalement
les difficultés de votre quotidien
oui je pense qu'elle a mis en lumière
donc ça fait ça va faire deux ans avec
le collectif interrogeant ce qu'on
dénonce les problématiques
aujourd'hui la crise sanitaire baird
permis de mettre plus en lumière ce que
l'on dénonce déjà c'est pas nouveau mais
voilà on en parle plus aujourd'hui et
puis il faut vraiment que le système de
santé dans sa globalité soit repensé
aujourd'hui et une absence de
reconnaissance de la part de l'exécutif
peut-être oui bien sûr mais c'est pas
c'est pas nouveau c'est pas ce
gouvernement non plus qui est qui a
commencé à la casse de l'hôpital ça fait
des années mais il ya un manque de
reconnaissance qui est évident alors on
va revenir sur la crise sanitaire vous
vos collègues du secteur du
médico-social comment avez vous vécu ces
derniers mois même sept dernières années
cette dernière année a été très
compliqué à cp ça a été difficile même
au niveau personnel vous savez on est on
est content tout le monde au début de
cette crise on était tous inquiet et
puis on a fini par part à vivre avec et
puis et puis s'adapter à chaque à chaque
changement dans nos professions
à s'adapter avec ce virus là travailler
avec aujourd'hui ça reste compliqué il
ya toujours des cas forcément on apprend
à vivre avec et puis on va voir sur les
mois commun les mois qui arrivent
comment ça se passe avec avec ce vaccin
est ce que vous avez vu un changement
dans les hôpitaux en général depuis le
mois de mars de l'année dernière et
maintenant est ce que vous avez senti
qu'il y avait eu une évolution tout de
même l'évolution s'il ya eu depuis tôt
négatives que positives les mes
collègues sur sur le territoire ainsi en
continu de deux firent l'hôpital public
parce qu'on n'a toujours pas les moyens
qu'on demande pour pouvoir accueillir
correctement et dignement les patients
c'est voilà le segura eu lieu certes
mais mehdi les qu'illusoire la seule
chose qu'on peut en voir ses 283 euros
pour les hospitaliers à la fin du mois
mais pour l'accueil de nos patients
c'est c'est complètement illusoire en
manque de lits on continue de supprimer
des guides des services entiers donc
c'est pas comme ça qu'on va réussir à
améliorer l'hôpital public et et la
santé de données en tout cas alors dans
le médico-social trois quarts 1,1 des
professionnels sont des femmes peut-on y
voir un lien de cause à effet dans le
médical en général c'est quand même très
féminin en tout cas dans le paramédical
dans le médico-social vous avez bien sûr
beaucoup beaucoup d'enseignants
d'infirmières mais il n'ya pas qu'eux il
ya aussi beaucoup d'éducateurs et il ya
beaucoup de professions je pourrais pas
toutes les citer que ce soient des
femmes ou des hommes
aujourd'hui je suis pas sûr qu'il faille
faire une distinction c'est comme mes
collègues
oui beaucoup de femmes c'est vrai c'est
un secteur où il ya beaucoup de femmes
n'y a pas que des femmes et faut pas
faire la distinction pour moi non une
bonne merci d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt front je rappelle que vous
êtes président du collectif inter
urgence à infirmière aux urgences
d'oloron sainte marie
merci d'avoir été en direct avec nous